-This weekend, Naomi Osaka
played Veronika Kudermetova
at BNP Paribas Open,
but the match was interrupted
when a woman in the crowd
yelled, "Naomi, you suck!"
An incident that brought Osaka
to tears.
Here to comment, is one of our
writers Amber Ruffin, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
Hi.
Yeah, hi.
Hey. Hi.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
You guys, thank you.
Hi, Seth!
It really made me mad
when this happened
because
I love her so much.
So I just wanted to drop by with
a special message of support
for Naomi Osaka.
Naomi, we are so proud of you
and we love you.
And we're gonna support you
no matter what you do.
-Aw. That's very nice.
-I've also got a message
for her heckler.
I'm gonna find you.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna find you and I'm gonna
rip you up
like a piece of paper.
You wanna yell,
"Naomi, you suck"?
Well, you know what sucks?
Your chances of survival.
-Amber!
Amber, you cannot say that.
-I can't say how I feel?
-No, you can't threaten people.
-Seth!
How could I even rip someone up
like a piece of paper?
That's not possible.
Unless I have freakishly strong
hands from years of doing
sign language and gymnastics.
-Amber!
-It's fine! I don't even know
who the heckler was!
You can tell I don't know who
she was because I'm not in jail.
Serving a life sentence for
slapping her to death
and then slapping her back to
life again.
-You can't say that!
-What?
I said I slap her back to life?
[ Laughter ]
Seth, no one knows who did it.
So technically, I'm not
threatening anyone when I say,
I'm gonna feed you beans.
I'm gonna rip off your face and
put it in your butt
and then the thing that kills
you will be your own farts.
[ Laughter ]
-That's enough! Look, just why
not concentrate on Naomi.
-Man, that child is strong.
She doesn't need me.
She doesn't need help from
anybody.
But you know who does need help?
You, you little heckling punk!
[ Laughter ]
Don't sleep 'cause I'm gonna
kill you in your dreams
like Freddy Krueger!
[ Laughter ]
One, two,
Amber's coming for you.
Three, four,
better shut the door.
-Amber!
-Five, six that was just for
kicks. Seth, I'm kidding!
-Amber,
this is all very unlike you.
-Seth, you're right.
And I'm sorry.
And I'd like to apologize.
Hey, little heckler.
I'm sorry
for what I'm gonna so to your
face, 'cause girl,
when I find you --
-Stop it!
-I'm gonna hug you.
-Okay.
-Till I squeeze all the air out.
[ Laughter ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.